what's up tracy how do my husband and i
tell his parents my in-laws
um that we're not gonna have anything to
do
with my brother-in-law who is soon to be
released from prison
without it sounding like i don't like a
declaration of war you know like
you know like you have to pick a side
i don't know i don't know that you can
it sounds like you've
declared war and you've picked a side
well
no we don't want them to feel like they
have to pick a side
but we want to make it clear that like
we're not going to have anything to do
with him and so like he's not invited to
our house
we won't be attending gatherings that
he's at but we're happy to be
you know flexible if they're gonna do
things together you
you know we're not gonna say well
christmas dinner is at our house at noon
be there or don't what did this guy do
um that's irredeemable
so he's in prison for
committing burglaries okay um
but leading up to that he had stolen
over fifty thousand dollars from
my in-laws that's their issue yeah our
our
issue is that while he's been in prison
he has sent
hundreds of letters to
my in-laws house where we used to live
talking about
all kinds of crazy and violent things
including fratricide
and he also thinks that my nine-year-old
step-daughter
my husband's is his spirit child
and he is spiritually her father
whoa and and that combined with the
violent letters makes
so we're not willing to risk
her or my husband yeah so are
your in-laws planning on welcoming them
back with open arms or are they going to
get a restraining order the moment he
gets out of jail
i i don't i mean my mother-in-law just
tried to buy a house for him
that didn't pass the home plan so he's
not actually going to be really he was
scheduled to be released this coming
saturday yeah but because it didn't pass
the home plan
he's not coming but now we're like okay
we need to have this conversation
because i mean the main issue is really
my stepdaughter
because i'll die before i let him
near her so let's step back from him
because this is supercharged
okay this is really heavy let's back it
up and just say that your in-laws asked
you to go
camping in the arizona desert in august
as a family and they said hey this is
our jam this is what we do
you just married into this family little
lady we all go
camping in arizona in august it's hot
hot and we get sunburned it's kind of a
family tradition
in fact we we uh put little stickers on
our bodies
and we get sunburned all around them
we're just weirdos right
and you family did that that's not weird
just for the record tracy it's super
weird but
it's not it's not weird at all um but
you didn't know about this you married
him and then all of a sudden
one night uh y'all are laying in your
bed and
the lights are off and you just say hey
honey he's like yeah babe and you say
there's no chance i'm going camping in
arizona none zero and he starts laughing
he's like i was waiting for you to say
that i get that
and then you have to have that
conversation with his in-laws and it's
just as simple as
hey we love you guys we're not gonna go
camping this year
um but we can't wait to see you at the
holidays
and the more you try to explain
dramatize give
reasons examples on the back end the
more complicated and messy it gets
and so that's not a charge situation it
could become one depending on how cool
or lame your in-laws are but it is what
it is
when it comes to this this is somebody
who's demonstrated to you in your eyes
that
they're not safe that they don't intend
on being safe
they haven't been safe in the past
they're not going to be safe in the
future
and so it's just a very simple
we will not be communicating with this
person in any shape form or fashion in
any way
and we may even pursue um a restraining
order when they get out of jail
we don't want them near us near our um
daughter
and then we're gonna go happily about
our lives if you choose to have in their
life
great we will not be there and there's
just a period at the end of that
sentence said in a matter-of-fact way
not a good a war way not an angry way
but just a way that this is what's gonna
happen
as though the sky is blue and our grass
is somewhat green
and any sort of drama on the back end is
not yours you cannot
be responsible for how other people
experience your boundaries
you know what i mean yeah it's just
it's it sucks it's not your it's not you
didn't cause it but now it's in your lap
and you've got to deal with it right
right
i'm like somebody ring your door we're
really close and i
i guess i worry that like this is
definitely
going to be a barrier to that if your
in-laws choose for it to be it will be
that doesn't mean you're not doing the
right thing
it doesn't mean that it doesn't change
over time it doesn't mean that four
years later three years from now two
years from now this guy's out and he's
cool and he's doing his work and doing
his thing and
taking his med whatever he's got to be
doing and y'all make some concessions
and changes
but if you all don't feel safe if you
don't feel comfortable this is an easy
easy situation
an easy boundary to draw this isn't like
hey i don't like sleeping outside this
isn't like i don't want to drive halfway
across the country
i guess it's a simple boundary to draw
it's not an easy boundary to draw
because like it's just like you know
like it's
simple like it's straightforward and i
get that i guess i was you know
spoken like oh he's really good at stuff
maybe he'll have something to say that
won't upset
people and they'll just be like oh yeah
i totally get your viewpoint
there is when it comes to somebody who
has
lost perspective with one of their kids
there is no
rational conversation you can have
straightforward
as short as possible and then you
separate
that's it so whenever you're bringing
somebody in to let them go
to fire them from their job that should
be a very very short conversation
and we're going to let you go in a week
or two
we'll circle back and you can meet with
hr to get the specifics
that we've chosen at this time to let
you go yes would you ever let me do that
job
if you've got well it's it's the kindest
think about it ripping a band-aid off or
a surgeon
right do you want the surgeon to take
the blunt instrument
and just drag it across your poor little
leg no
you want to use the sharpest item
they've got the smallest
most precise tool and they want to make
a quick cut a concise cut and get it
done
right same thing here um
it cannot be a surprise to your in-laws
it can't be
unless they've just become delusional
too and that does happen
right when you're i parents like that
with students of mine that were that way
but we had to come to jesus talk
two christmases ago okay because i say
it's my in-laws but it's my
mother-in-law okay
you know my father-in-law if you take
him aside he is
totally against it but then he needs to
stand up too for the safety of his
family
and he's choosing not to so he's
choosing not to protect his family yeah
and you know my husband has two other
brothers and
vocally they're you know also like no he
can't be
back into our lives unless he's willing
to
go through all of the hoop of probation
and parole
and you know get on medication and get
help because clearly
what's in those letters like you cannot
be a sound mind yeah
so and i am so happy you're super lucky
here
so join forces together do that meeting
together
uh make sure everybody's on the same
page maybe even write a letter
and if you want to be really
straightforward and bold send him a
letter in jail
that because of your behavior because of
your letters you're not going to be
welcome
at our home until you do the following x
y and z
let him know up front so we can hold
this letter we love you we wish the best
for you
we can't help you at this time and the
the things that you're writing in these
letters are making us uncomfortable for
the protection of our family
you don't have to do that you can
you can write that letter to your mom or
your mother-in-law knowing that she's
probably going to show it to him right
but here's the thing there is no
shortcut to a hard conversation
say it be clear concise know exactly
what you want to say
and then get out and bail right it's as
straightforward as humanly possible
and there is no easy way to do it
there's no way that it doesn't
um isn't uncomfortable the quicker and
cleaner that cut
the quicker and cleaner it can heal
right
i just never even thought of that
surgery analogy until just now and i
think it works pretty good
all right let's take one more call thank
tracy thank you for that call it sucks
i do want to know how the conversation
goes though if you will have that
conversation with your in-laws
draw that line you're going to feel
weight leave your shoulders we've done
it this is it
you are not going to feel good when he
gets out of jail you're not
unless you get some sort of police
protection or some sort of come to jesus
conversation maybe between your husband
and him
in the jail before you leave some some
sort of closure conversation but
chances are this is going to be
something that's going to haunt your
family for the future and y'all have to
be really clear on your boundaries and
really direct